-Congratulations
on your St. Louis Blues.
-Congratulations to the Blues.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And you were actually suppose
to be on our show last night
and you asked us to move
so you could go to game seven.
-Yes, thank you
for switching me around.
-Of course, I was so happy
you got to be there.
This is an organization that
has never won a Stanley Cup.
-Never. And they went
from worst to first.
They were the worst team
in the NHL
in the beginning of January,
and last night,
they won the Stanley Cup
in Boston.
-So that was
an interesting thing.
'Cause did you go
to game six in St. Louis?
-I didn't.
-You didn't?
-And so there were a lot of,
sort of, famous St. Louis fans
Some celebrities
who like the team,
but you were the only one
who showed up to Boston.
-I was, yeah.
It was me.
I was the chump that showed up
It's black and yellow
everywhere at the Garden,
and here I am
wearing this jersey.
I'm like, "Hey, everybody!
-Not a historically welcomin
fan base, the people of Boston
-No, and I literally,
truly thought
I was gonna get beaten up.
Yes.
So, what I found was,
that people either wanted
to give me the finger
or take a selfie.
That was the pendulum
swinging back and forth.
But ultimately,
inside the Garden,
I gotta tell you something -
people were really cool.
And then, about midway through
the second period,
I felt the energy
start to shift.
-Yeah.
-And there was no one to blame
but me and my friend Fred,
basically,
who were wearing
the Blues uniforms.
So it got a little --
I was like,
"Just let's bring it down.
Let's not cheer so loud."
-Gotcha.
-People were super cool,
though, ultimately.
-Did anybody yell anything
that felt very Boston to you
-Yeah, they were just like
"You'll never be a legend!
[ Laughter ]
-So great.
-"I know. You're right."
-That is so --
-I mean, it's true.
All right.
And then they were like,
they actually --
the people behind me,
truly wanted to rip
Bennington limb from limb.
-Yes, that's the sort of
otherworldly goalie.
IS this Pat Muldoon, here?
-That's Pat Maroon.
-Maroon, sorry, excuse me.
-He's also from St. Louis.
-So, yeah,
and he played for Edmonton
-He played for Edmonton.
I was sitting next to him
on a plane a couple years ago.
He was like,
"Hey, I play hockey.
I'm from St. Louis."
And now he's on the Blues,
and he's a real hometown hero.
I love the guy.
That was on the ice
after the game.
It was so exciting.
I'm still so high
from this thing.
-You were back in town
in Thanksgiving
when they were not
a good hockey team.
-Yes! We kind of
partied with the Blues.
I ran into them in a bar
after a loss.
They had lost and I guess
were partying after the game
and people on social media
were like,
"Why are you guys partying
You're horrible.
Like, what are you doing?"
-And then it turned around
It all worked.
Sometimes, it's just helpful
to be together.
I want to congratulate you
on this, as well.
10-year anniversary
of "Watch What Happens."
-Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Things are cool.
-It is a show that I alway
have the best time doing.
I don't think I'm alone.
I think you make it a very fun
place for guests to be.
What do you have planned
for this week of shows?
-We're going to be on at 10:00
for two weeks,
which is super fun for me,
because I get
to do everything earlier.
And we got
a lot of big surprises,
and it's insane looking back and
seeing, like, "Did that happen?"
I can't believe it.
We have --
The Countess Luann is gonn
perform her new song
on the show.
-Wow!
We've been trying to get her
to do the song here.
-I know.
Jimmy, too. Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Most importantly,
as we are going through the list
of things to congratulate
you for.
You're about to have your firs
Father's Day as a dad.
-I am!
Yes, I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at this little guy.
-There he is.
-4 months old.
-So cute.
Yeah, it's amazing.
That's my son, Ben.
-Ben.
And how's it changed so far?
-Everything has changed.
I mean, everything has changed
It's amazing.
He's a little love bug.
Besides all of the love,
the gear, dude.
-Oh, man.
-Oh, my God.
-The gear.
-It's like, no,
that's an adapter for that
And then you need that
to do that.
It's absolutely insane.
And I've got --
I used to be Mr. Summer.
I don't know
if you knew that about me.
-Yeah, you were Mr. Summer
You were a summer guy.
-I was a mobile unit, I could go
anywhere, light as a feather
Flip-flops,
maybe bring my dog, maybe not,
had a convertible.
Like, wow, now --
I was in the market to get a
SUV to schlep all the stuff.
-Yeah.
-I'm like, "Wow,
I'm so weighted down,"
and it happened
when I was partnering with
"Autotrader," which is cool,
which is the leading resourc
for every kind of car.
And they helped me find an SUV
and I kept looking.
They have this list of
the best new cars of 2019.
I keep looking at the -- I kee
looking at the convertibles.
-Oh, yeah, they don't want
you to have that.
-No, I am going to the SUV
I got an SUV.
I'm a soccer mom.
-Well, people keep telling me,
like,
"Don't look away from minivans."
Like, don't sleep on minivans.
-Oh, right, no.
I hear they're the best.
-So I got a friend
who used to be cool as [bleep]
He's like,
"Dude, you need a minivan.
And I'm like --
[ Laughter ]
-But you said,
he used to be cool as [bleep
-Yeah, no, I'm not --
I'm like --
But he still thinks it's cool.
He's driving around --
I mean, I guess you let
that part of the brain die
that judges it,
and then you just rock aroun
in a minivan.
How are you, like, getting
the stroller collapsed?
Are you good at it?
-Starting to be better.
We flew to L.A.
two weeks ago for the week
and flying with the gear
and taking the elevator up
instead of the escalator,
I'm like, here, I can just til
it on the escalator.
They're like, "No, you can't
actually do that with him.
Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-It sounds like
you're going really well.
It does sound like
you're going well.
-I'm really depressed.
I was excited about Father's Day
a while ago.
-You should be.
It is the greatest
joy in the world.
Thanks so much
for being here, man.
Congratulations.